cientos de mujeres turcas pero sobre
todo iraníes se han reunido hoy en
Estambul para protestar y solarizarse
con las protestas en Irán que llevan
ocurriendo desde hace algo más de dos
semanas por la muerte de la joven masa a
mini a manos de la policía moral de su
país de Irán
estoy aquí porque quiero decir que estoy
en contra de que nos obliguen a llevar
queremos Libertad
en Irán protestamos por la libertad por
la mala economía porque un pequeño grupo
de mulas fanáticos están en el poder por
esto protestamos en su contra
lo único que queremos es un cambio de
régimen en Irán
gritan todas mujeres y libertad y muerte
al dictador En referencia a laiatola de
Irán Ali jamenehi la siraníes dentro del
país y también fuera buscan un cambio
total de régimen en el país persa
donde estamos encierran y tapan
forzosamente Aunque no queramos en
nombre de la religión las mujeres en
Irán son puestas en la cárcel y no nos
permiten tener una vida normal y libre
se meten en nuestras vidas privadas
es mi casa mi amor Así que todo lo que
pasa en Irán deben irnos a todos para
derrotar al dictador para traerle la
libertad a la gente
todas las iraníes presentes aquí en
Estambul cuentan que tienen familiares
en Irán participando activamente en las
protestas que ocurren desde hace más de
dos semanas y cuentan todos que están
preocupados por no poder tener noticias
de sus familiares ya que Irán ha cortado
internet durante esta ola de prote